all right hi everyone thank you for
coming and today I'm here I'm happy to
be here to talk about my work
translating some of my favorite deer
functions to DBT and more broadly what
I've learned about the power of
translating syntax to share ideas
between different communities in the
data space and I think one of the
reasons it's really exciting to be back
here at posit comp is we all share the
same language so when we're talking to
each other in the hallway we don't have
to talk about oh you know that guy who's
WR all the packages that have heex logos
we can just say hadly and everyone knows
who we're talking about and similarly
Beyond kind of those fun Concepts and
that internal language this also helps
Elevate important Concepts and
accelerates more technical conversations
for example instead of manually
describing oh that's certain way to
structure data if we just say tidy data
we know what we mean it elevates that
concept and we can springboard into
whatever we're saying about that concept
but while these internal languages can
really help communication within a
community sometimes they can make it
actually harder to communicate with our
peers that come from other backgrounds
such as data science versus data
engineering or R versus
python and what I found as I've moved
between some of those different job
families and responsibilities and
languages
in my own work is that translating
syntax between languages can be a
powerful way to transport Concepts
across
communities and one recent experience I
had with this was when I translated some
of my favorite functions functionality
from DLI to DBT which is the data
engineering and data pipelining
framework coming from the deeper world I
found that I could find a lot of really
useful and interesting workflows with
the strategic use of column names then
as I began to produce more data sets for
consumption by other people I began to
realize that I could turn um pull this
idea further Upstream into the Strategic
creation of column names but to get
others in the data engineering and
analytics engineering space to do the
same I had to build that same incentive
structure that existed in D flier in the
stack of tools used by data Engineers
which motivated me to make the
translation to BT so for the rest of our
time today I want to tell three parts of
this story first the con underlying
Concepts that I was able to learn from
the deep flyer language secondly how I
realized column names themselves could
be a type of micr language to
communicate between
communities and then finally how I
encouraged myself and wearing an
engineering hat and other analytics
Engineers to do the same by bringing
deer functionality
to DBT but first let's start with deer
as many of you may have seen in your own
work deer contains number of helpful
tidy select functions which kind of
imply the existence of having of column
names having meaning and being something
we can act on and operate so we have
functions such as starts with ends with
and
contains and how these work is that
these uh selectors when applied to a
data set help us pick out column names
that follow certain patterns for example
finding all count variables that maybe
start with something like n or finding
all variables that relate to some
concept like containing the word spend
somewhere within them and this simple
idea of expecting column names to have a
pattern and have a meaning unlocks the
idea of them being something we can
program against and operate on and it
incentivizes the Strategic use of column
names for this General p pattern of find
columns and do something and this became
very useful in many aspects of my data
science data analysis work in
transformation in modeling and in
validation so just to give a few
examples using something like de plier
for data wrangling we can find columns
and then use that for more efficient
transformation if we want to do
something as simple as the data
aggregation instead of writing the same
aggregation function for example taking
the mean of every indic a variable to
calculate a proportion we can write that
line of code once and have it applied to
all relevant
variables in the modeling context this
unlocks different capabilities of find
columns and do something else like
present prevent model leakage often when
I'm modeling I like to keep variables in
my data set that should not be used as
predictors in that model but might be
useful to help me diagnose weak spots in
the model as I'm looking to enhance
future
performance but with the package like
recipes to ensure that I don't
accidentally include these as predictors
I can name those features variables
strategically find those columns and
assign them to a role that ensures that
they don't enter into the wrong part of
the modeling
Pipeline and finally for something like
data validation I can find columns and
do something like double check that
those columns those variables are
behaving as I expected
using a package like Point Blank for
example if I think all of my variables
that start with n should be counts I can
test that hypothesis in a single line of
code and then if I update those
variables later if I add more columns
into my data set that fit this pattern
my Texs will automatically expand to
comprehensively test all of the
variables in my data set even as the
individual variables
change so in my own work in the data
science and data analysis space space I
found this simple idea of being able to
find column names and expect meaning in
those to be really useful so much so
that I started to think about column
names in and of themselves as a kind of
language so as I moved in and out of the
data science Rules into at times more
analytics engineering or data
engineering um type
responsibilities I thought about how I
could operationalize this concept to not
just um have meaningful column names for
myself
but to better communicate between data
producers and data consumers by
embedding meaning in those column names
for others column names are themselves a
form of abstraction that um capture the
messiness and the complexity and the
rich underlying meaning of a data set so
to do this I started thinking about
names not just as words but more like
sentences or paragraphs so I started
thinking about defining sets of stubs
that cancode different types of
semantics and different types of
performance contracts about my data and
then when going to name columns for a
data set I intended to publish permuting
those together to create a rich
combinatorial explosion of intuitive and
really meaningful um column names so to
just give a few examples of how this is
useful you can imagine maybe defining
one layer that captures something like
the rough types or intended use cases of
variables
so for example ID indicator count date
hopefully many of these seem fairly
intuitive that's the goal but beyond
intuition alone we can Define very
explicit semantics for these variables
so people know exactly what these things
should mean when they look at them for
example an indicator variable would be a
01 indicator and the rest of the name
would always describe the positive case
so we could push towards more um
more um specific names and not have
ambiguity of which case encodes the
positive versus the negative but beyond
semantics we can also use these stubs to
make promises to the users of our data
so for example indicator variables
perhaps always being non-null or dates
always being in everyone's favorite ISO
format and similarly you can imagine
doing the same process as other layers
as it relates to your specific use case
and tackling some of those gnarly
problems in our Enterprise such as
everyone having a different definition
of what is a user or what is a
customer if we Define for a specific
stub a singular meaning for something
like a user we can then use that um
concept and that definition consistently
throughout all of our data sets to push
towards more clarity and again that
better communication across different
job families and areas of
responsibility and Beyond encoding
semantics and contracts we can also
encode the consequences of those choices
so for example if users are identified
by IP addresses sometimes that may
result in
inconsistencies and identification
across
devices and so forth and so on you can
imagine this process playing out
differently in different Enterprises but
the idea being want for once Define and
align on this common language and then
use that to create
Rich latent communication between
different families and the benefits of
this pattern were really really clear to
me having UND come from the perspective
first of that data science that data
analyst user of how they would interpret
and use these names but to encourage
other um you others on the data
production side to use this same pattern
I found that I had to trans make one
more set of translation and translate
this concept into toing used by
analytics engineers and data Engineers
so they could also benefit and see the
really see it and experience for
themselves the value of this sort of
workflow and this sort of pattern and
that's what encouraged me to take those
tidy select helpers that inspired my own
workflows and translate them into a DBT
package called DBT platter now for those
that aren't familiar with DBT I'll just
say a few brief words about what that is
DBT is a data engineering framework that
largely sits on top of the SQL language
and helps people build better quality
data pipelines by encoding software
engineering best practices such as
enabling clean code with variables and
control flow like if statements and for
Loops that you can't necessarily do
natively in SQL um promoting more
organized projects for better structure
and
reproducibility and adding some um
syntactic sugar for better developer
workflows with things like testing
logging and
orchestration so although it's a
different language and a different
framework I felt like the DBT community
and the DBT language already shared a
lot of the same underlying values as the
r community in the way that we valued
the scientific quality and
reproducibility and the idea of bringing
these best practices from these
different fields into the data space and
just to give one example of how DBT does
this you may be familiar with a
traditional SQL query that really
doesn't follow the dry principles of do
not repeat yourself there's a lot of
redundancy a lot of repeated copypaste
business logic which can cause a lot of
room for error but DBT by adding
variables and adding for Loops we're
able to get a lot closer to that dry
streamlined workflow that um is probably
more comfortable to many of us coming
from more traditional coding languages
as well as in coding a lot of our
business logic in macros and
packages and because of this packaging
ecosystem I was able to write a DBT
package called TBT plier which
translates all those select helpers that
I knew and loved and found so many
applications for in my art based
workflows to DBT so we have all those
same functionalities like starts with
ends with and
contains and what this same pattern
looks like as it plays out in the DBT
workflow is something like this once
again we can find columns and do stuff
whatever that stuff may be first we can
um find column names that match some
sort of a
pattern next in a select statement we
can apply whatever transformation we
wish to all of the variables matching
that pattern and similar to DB D plier
if we so choose we can do similar things
in filter statements and where
Clauses but to me the most exciting part
of making this transformation wasn't
simply copying the functionality of deer
to unlock the same workflows but rather
seeing by translating the concept of
column names to D DBT and therefore to
the analytics and data engineering
community finding slightly different
applications for them when used and
applied in that space and in turn these
um
these applications helped better soothe
common pain points of communication
between data engineers and data
scientists so for example tackling
problems such as um VAR data sets with
inconsistent naming unreliable and
untrustworthy meaning and unvalidated or
poorly tested um data sets so to just
show how this fully played out in the
dbtt context you can imagine as a data
user how frustrating it can be when your
column names don't follow a good pattern
I'm sure many of us have been in the
case where our code breaks their errors
out because we failed to replicate some
error that exists Upstream in a data set
but with the package like but with
simply the idea embedded in DBT now of
column names really being this thing we
can act on and structure instead of
writing this really manual redundant SQL
code the tends to lend itself to those
sorts of sloppy
typos we can pull in the variables and
macros and um controlflow that's um
embedded within the DB DBT um
framework to um only write that code
once and loop over all of the relevant
variables so by embedding the concept of
having VAR structured column names we're
incentivized to change our code to fit
that pattern and create and avoid those
typos for our users
users but beyond typos even more
frustrating for data users is broken
contracts that lie to our users so for
example if we have a variable that's
called a date but is actually cast as a
timestamp this is more than a mild
annoyance if someone makes the mistake
of trusting you and filtering that
column as if it were a date they may
risk throwing away all of their data and
not retrieving any of the records that
they intended to but by the combination
now of DBT and DBT plier we can catch
this process earlier on in our data
Pipeline and avoid this type of error so
for example we could think about
manually casting every variable that
we're calling a date to a date but this
could get a little fragile and a little
sketchy if we actually if we add a
variable to our data set and forget to
adjust this sort of
transformation but with the power of DBT
plier we can find all of our variables
that match pattern
and write Dynamic and flexible code that
will ensure that we enforce that
contract universally no matter how our
shape of that shape of our data set
changes or evolves over time and yet you
can probably also Imagine a time where
this could be a really bad idea for
example imagine trying to cast
automatically cast a date variable to
make sure variables called n stay as
integers if something Upstream in your
pipeline is broken and those variables
aren't actually integers you wouldn't be
solving a problem by doing this sort of
casting You' just actually be covering
it up and making it harder to
debug so with dbts testing
infrastructure we can write um tests
that run in our pipeline before we
execute certain Transformations for
example we could check that no matter
what type of variable is currently cast
at it's that we could make sure it's
sufficiently close to an integer that
we're comfortable doing that casting
operation and once again with the
framework of DBT plier and with this
concept of operating and programming
against our column names as a shared
latent form of communication throughout
our data space um we can automate this
check to make sure it too runs
comprehensively so as you move
throughout different roles and
responsibilities in your career or as
you work in on C in cross functional
initiatives I found that aligning on
these core ideas across our different
communities and creating shared
languages for them both in words in
Frameworks and in syntax can be a really
powerful tool for
collaboration so thank you all for your
time if you're interested in talking
more about DBT DBT plier or select
helpers or column names please find me
anytime throughout the conference and
I've Linked In My slides a number of
resources um kind of about the mattering
of topics that I covered today thank
[Applause]
you